foreign two sets of remains identified
two people yet to be named our eight
news now investigators broke the news of
a murder victim found in a barrel at
Lake Mead almost one year ago so how
close is the coroner's office to
identifying who that man was along with
another set of remains found floating
nearby eight news now investigator David
charns asked the coroner
do you think we're close in figuring out
who these people are it would be very
difficult to place a time frame on it
Clark County coroner Melanie Rouse is
talking about the human remains found at
Lake Mead her office has yet to identify
one a murder victim discovered in a
barrel in May the second a floating
torso from July we view identification
as a very important part of what we do
giving a name back to a decedent that
we've recovered that process includes
using all information available to
figure out who these people are
investigators here have pulled DNA
samples from both sets of remains is it
fair to say that
the DNA tests so far have turned up no
match it is still being processed so
again you're only as good as what you
can compare to what is the difficulty in
solving these cases
the challenge in solving cases is that
we're really only good at the
information that exists for us to
compare to Rouse says her office was
able to identify two Lake Mead drowning
victims discovered last year from
missing persons reports and DNA
sometimes remains may never be able to
be identified again if the information
doesn't exist for comparison there's not
a magic tool out there for us to just
say this is who the person is who this
person is may be even more difficult to
solve as the 8 news now investigators
reported last year the man is believed
to have died in the early 1980s based on
personal items found nearby there was no
National DNA crime database then we are
working through the investigative
process and following up on any
available leads that we have as for
solving these cases and all unidentified
remains in our office's custody Rouse
says the more information the better
it's not too late to come forward and to
try to make an identification there is
no deadline to give the corner or police
any information if you think one of
these people is your loved one you can
file a missing person's case or you can
always call Metro Police outside the
coroner's office I'm David charns eight
news now as David mentioned the
coroner's office has identified two sets
of skeletal remains discovered at Lake
Mead last year one is a 42 year old Las
Vegas man who drowned in 2002 just last
week the office identified the second
set as a 39 year old man who died in
1974.